et moselle et moselle
mesdemoiselles vous voilà arrivés à la
fin de votre dernière année d'études
dans notre chère institutions
d'éducation sexuelle
vous êtes actuellement de grandes jeunes
filles oui vous êtes de grandes jeunes
filles maintenant et vous devez savoir
que les enfants arrivent à cheval si
j'ose dire sur les cigognes et qu'elles
viennent remplir nos cheminées de petits
enfants tout rose enroulés dans leur
l'ange au milieu du bec de la fameuse
cigognes précédemment cités maintenant
comment procède t exactement le papa et
la maman est bien le soir lorsqu'ils
sont dans la chambre à coucher
le papa baisse la lumière et sort son
catalogue
alors là à sa voie là le papa et la
maman commente un petit frère ou une
petite soeur par la poste
et puisque vous ne devez pas ignorer
ceux ci en ce dernier jour comment
reconnaît reconnaît-on les petits
garçons des petites filles
moi je sais je sais je sais elle est
bien au rock oui j'oubliais c'est très
simple
soulever les draps et l heure à ce
moment là on peut simplement distinguer
que les petites filles ont des layette
rose et les petits garçons des layettes
bleus